Anlässlich des bevorstehenden österreichischen EU-Ratsvorsitzes
präsentierte Verteidigungsminister Mario Kunasek
die Sicherheitspolitischen Schwergewichte und Beiträge des Bundesheeres.
Wir haben zwei Schwergewichtssetzungen.
Das Eine sind Unterstützunsleistungen,
die wir treffen im Rahmen des Flottenmanagements mit Fahrern/Chauffeuren.
Aber auch Assistenzleistungen, die entsprechend vorfallen können.
Nämlich für das Innenministerium, wo wir
auch Kräfte bereithalten und natürlich auch
im Bereich der Luftraumoperation, wo wir auch in der Luft für Sicherheit sorgen.
Der zweite große Bereich ist der inhaltliche Bereich.
Wo wir auch in sicherheitspolitischen Bereichen uns einbringen werden, nämlich wenn es darum geht
für die Sicherung der Außengrenze, als
Beispiel, wo wir mit dem Assistenzeinsatzmodell,
das es seit Jahrzenten in Österreich auf hervorragende Art und Weise
gemeinsam mit dem Innenresor gibt, Lösungen zu finden.
Aber selbstverständlich auch Lösungen für den Westbalkan zu erarbeiten, wo ich ganz offen
sage, das ist ein Bereich wo man Stabilität und Frieden braucht, nur dann,
kann es Stabilität und Frieden auch in Österreich und in Europa geben.
Neben der Luftraumüberwachung gab auch das Kommando Schnelle Einsätze, die Erstreaktionskraft
des Bundesheeres, vor Journalisten in der Maria-Theresien-Kaserne einen kleinen Einblick in ihre Fähigkeiten.
Das Kommando Schnelle Einsätze ist ein Verband, den es seit 1 1/2 Jahren gibt.
Es ist ein Verband der natürlich militärische Aufgaben zu erfüllen hat,
nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein Verband der auch einen Auftrag hat, nämlich die Unterstützung bei der Aufrechterhaltung
der Sicherheit und Ordnung, sollte das benötigt werden,
sollte es die Anforderung der Sicherheitsbehörden geben.
Wir haben verschiedenste Fähigkeiten in diesem Verband.
Militärstreife, Elemente der ABC-Abwehrtruppe, Pioniere, Infanterie, Aufklärung, Logistikelemente.
Alle können in irgendeiner Art und Weise dazu beitragen,
dass die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft sichergestellt werden kann.
Das Kommando Logistik koordiniert das umfangreiche EU-Transportmanagement.
Für den Einsatz im Rahmen der EU-Ratspräsidentschaft, 1. Juli bis 31. Dezember,
werden hierfür von Porsche Österreich
an die 160 Farhzeuge gesponsort.
Die Übergabe erfolgte symbolisch durch den Verteidigungsminister.
Österreich hat, nach 1998 und 2006, das dritte Mal den Vorsitz über die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft.
Das Bundesheer ist großartig vorbereitet.
Es ist für uns nicht das erste Mal, dass
wir eine Veranstaltung wie diese auch entsprechend abarbeiten,
dass heißt ich gehe davon aus, dass es hier reibungslos funktioniert,
appelliere aber natürlich auch an alle die hier eingesetzt sind, diese Verantwortung auch zu leben,
das Bundesheer darzustellen und Werbung im besten Sinne zu machen.
Wir leisten viel und wir müssen es auch entsprechend
darstellen.
Deshalb freue ich mich auch auf die nächsten
sechs Monate.